[bright music]
Nteff: I'm Alain Nteff.
I'm a 23-year-old
Cameroonian.
I'm from a very
modest background,
from a single-mom family
in Bamenda.
While growing up,
I've always wanted
to be a medical doctor,
but to innovate
in the medical space,
you need, like,
30 years of experience.
But then I realized that,
with mobile technology,
I could innovate
and generate change
in people's lives
a lot faster.
Tankou: I'm Conrad Tankou.
As a doctor,
one of my biggest fights
is to try to solve this problem
of maternal
and infant mortality,
and trying to use technology
to be able to attend this
in even rural areas
is one of the greatest
things for me.
Nteff:
The question on our minds was,
"How come we still have maternal
infant mortality
being such a very big problem?"
After doing research,
we noticed that it was
a problem of education.
We saw mobile
as a very good channel
due to the penetration,
and together with Dr. Conrad,
we decided to start GiftedMom.
Tankou:
GiftedMom is an application
which contains basic
and simplified information
concerning pregnancy,
breastfeeding,
and vaccination for children.
The beginning was
really an adventure,
but when we built the app
and started testing,
it was really exciting,
because the reaction of those
who were using the app--
they were really excited.
It was a technology--
some of them had never seen
something like that before,
and also having
everything on one app--
all of them wanted to have it.
Nteff:
It was very important for us
to build
the GiftedMom application
to make it lightweight
in such a way that
it can easily be downloaded.
Also, we provided content
that can be accessible
even offline.
Tankou: The network coverage
in Cameroon is very good.
Even in some rural areas
where you don't
find electricity,
you can really have
access to the internet.
Nteff: We've noticed that 70% of
smartphone users across Africa
are on Android;
I want to leverage on this
to have 5 million users
across the continent
in the next three years.
Tankou: Consider the fact
that maternal mortality
and infant mortality
is a worldwide problem.
One of our objectives is not
only to concentrate in Cameroon
but spread this concept
to other developing countries.
Nteff:
Spending a lot of resources
and building health facilities
is going to come,
but in a very long time.
But with smartphone penetration,
we can actually provide people
with lifesaving information.
Seeing the GiftedMom app
on the Play Store
was very exciting for us,
because it was one of our first
products out there,
and it was just amazing
how we could sit in our rooms,
create something,
put it out there,
and it's accessible
to the whole world.
Tankou: When we were
building the application,
some [indistinct] medical
professionals were like,
"Is this going to work?
"Are you sure that what
you're aiming to build
is going to be that productive?"
And when it came out,
all of them were shocked,
and they were like,
encouraged,
and they went through the app
and gave us all this ideas
to develop it more.
It makes me really proud,
and it's also, like,
motivational
to keep moving forward, yeah.
Nteff:
It has been very inspiring
just seeing the app
that we have done
actually serving a purpose
in our rural communities,
and each time a woman
in this rural area
just loads the application
and we see popping up,
"GiftedMom,"
it's like--
there's just this joy, man,
and you're like,
"I'm going to go do better."